[Music]
director of the last of us
and last of us too respectively you know
what john why don't you take it away oh
you're the real gamer between us
take it away what did greg miller ask
neil drucken on twitter
ign's greg miller says hypothetical
question at neil druckmann
what established intellectual property
would you want to make a game
for to which dr uckman replies
number five cowboy bebops it's good it's
good you win with number five first
because you're the one
that's the revealed or the thing that
miami ghost rider half-life and the
punisher
punisher that's the main takeaway
because that was number one
on his list now john you're a massive
gamer massive absolutely last of us fans
played a lot of games
you've played a lot of levels especially
in the past five to ten years yeah i'll
let you take it away first because
i feel like i might step over your toes
here little
points so why don't you take it away
first and i'll go into it
yes well having having now played the
first chapter of the last of us
which was how long ago which was like
last weekend i think
oh congratulations thanks for trying new
stuff and 21.
yeah having played that first chapter
through and just seeing the way that
that game
juxtaposes its gameplay mechanics with
actual
cinematics in something of a different
way than say playing like a metal gear
game
i feel like you could actually yeah have
your cake and eat it too where you could
get a really satisfying
violent video game that has all the
tension that you want but that also
takes time to really have engaging and
enthralling cut scenes and storylines
and themes and whatnot and so while i
don't want this to turn into hatred
the uh video game that you reacted to a
while back you know at the same time i
feel like this actually could be a
medium
and a studio who could take a character
like the punisher who seems like
truly realizing him in cinema is going
to be kind of tricky at the moment
especially with marvel at disney this
actually seems like it could be a really
cool and innovative idea to take some of
these stories forward
yeah i mean going off that ladder point
i think that
yes we heard that deadpool 3 will be
rated r but that's a different type of r
rating
what to the po like i don't think that
when they finally do bring punisher
officially into the mcu that it's gonna
be like the ray stevenson lexi alexander
version i feel like they'd want to honor
it and keep it a little bit more akin to
the john
bernthal version that we got on netflix
that's
just my prediction i doubt they're gonna
go down the fun punisher route here
the punisher with neil druckmann doing
this i think you have to look no further
than just the last of us video games
specifically the last of us too
already i know that's upset some people
because of the fact of how
massively divisive that game is despite
the fact that it kicked a lot of ass
at the game awards just saying yes but
that was like a pretty much a 50 50
split with that game and i was on the
side of the video of my buddy pat
on this channel where i talked about why
i really love that video game a hell of
a lot and i think
just looking at that game alone and i
feel like even if you haven't played
that one but you played at least the
first last of us game a
the mood the tone that
type of dread can really capture
the personality the internal life that
frank castle is constantly living as and
also with the last of us too
that whole massive video game has one
underlying theme throughout which is
revenge or vengeance and frank castle's
whole mo
the whole thing about that guy is all
hell bent on vengeance his family was
taken away from him frank castle now
takes it out on the criminals
and i think if you look at that
beautifully captured scene in daredevil
season two when frank castle
and matt murdock are arguing on the
rooftop about the difference in their
philosophies
what it means to take a life and you
have that whole theme combined with what
neil druckmann loves to
explore about revenge from the last of
us too throw that
into your cinematic violent mood piece
of a video game you would have a
perfect punisher story to tell
i love the idea of neil druckmann
doing a punisher video game the
insomniac games have been
killing it with the spider-man franchise
undoubtedly i love the first spider-man
i love spider-man miles morales as well
there is the avengers game
which um i haven't played i know jon
has definitely i'm definitely gonna be a
hundred percent that is
cyberpunk 2077 all day long trying to
catch up with all children
right man all the most relevant games
the avengers game
i've heard the reviews i know a few
people in my personal life who
the trajectory of how it went was they
got the demo and loved it once they got
past the demo and started playing the
actual game their enthusiasm
for it began to decline so i'm kind of
going off of that maybe when i play it
i'll be like i don't know what all my
friends are talking about this game is
awesome but i really feel like they
ought to mix it up a little bit
and i think to do this with the punisher
would be a bold step
in the marvel games i think everyone
expects me to hear the marvel games to
be something like
a little bit more lighthearted kind of
like avengers or
like the spider-man games which yeah can
get a little bit gritty here or there
sure but you could even have some
crossover bleed into it kingpin is
in spider-man as a prevailing character
in the spider-man games or
at least the first one and he's in
spider-man miles morales
you could take that same kingpin and
have him come over
to this punisher game if you wanted him
to
so they can still connect in their own
way and while the spider-man games live
a little bit more in the
super heroic world it would be cool to
get your real
grounded take on it where you know you
got frank castle
fighting all his video you're fighting
jigsaw but you can have some daredevil
villains crossover you have daredevil
appear in this game the way how the
netflix series were about exploring the
needy underground world the more
grounded stylized take on the mcu you
could do that
alone here with this punisher game and
have those kind of heroes show up here
mainly focusing on frank castle neil
druckmann whether or not you like
the execution of what he did with the
last of us two or not he
cares heavily about story he cares
heavily about
characters like i said you might not
like the way
he goes about executing it but you
cannot
say what he does is lazy or that he
doesn't put
his heart into it and he does not try
liking it is one thing
but you cannot deny him the effort is
what i'm saying
and peering in from the outside it
certainly seems as though he really took
a strong
swing with the last yeah rather than
just like copping out or whatever
so like you know even if it is divisive
in a punisher scenario i would imagine
that at least whatever he could come up
with would be
distinct and interesting i mean well i
don't want to spoil the last of us too
for anyone especially since
you are almost i'm almost done with it i
don't want to spoil anything
i will say that one thing that was
revealed and i think is well known at
this point i'll leave out a massive
spoiler for you but
one little spoiler is that you play
halfway through in the last of us two as
the villain of in
in the game now that was problematic
just hearing that
when the leaks were coming out that you
halfway through you play as this
character
um through a good chunk of the game man
if you did some step like that with the
punisher oh my god you could play as a
marble
if you're like you know what that's
actually kind of cool i'm actually on
board for that yeah that could be the
coolest first mission
you're playing as a thug and then at the
very end of the first
mission chapter whatever the punisher
comes in kills you and you switch roles
i just think that thematically with
everything that is in tune with the
punisher
i think the one concern that i would
have is that it would feel a little bit
too much like the last of us
part two in terms of mood tone and
themes that you would explore the theme
songs would be exactly the same
even when i look at the punisher netflix
show the kind of music they had for
their
dark blues is the kind of music you can
expect in the last of us
as well this seems i could i totally see
why he
listed this as his number one game uh of
the once you want to adapt half-life
sounds cool
ghosts right like all all these games
sound cool
half-life but i think out of all the
ones neil druckmann i i honestly believe
i championed for him to be a perfect
pick
to adapt the last uh to adapt the
punisher video game i haven't talked
about it all in this video until now
sure
would you want to get troy baker or
somebody to fill in the shoes or one of
the
go-to mocap voiceover actor characters
for them
maybe i think get john bernthal man
he was in a tom i think it was a ghost
recon game
or a rainbow six one of them it was me
and earl and the dying girl
he was in a tom clancy game sure we've
seen his image in there already but come
on man frank castle
john bernthal get him to carry on in the
punisher video game
to play maybe punisher for the first
time starts doing some parkour
be cool and then if you beat the games
enough you can get skins of all the
previous actors to play them yeah
thomas jane's skin you get ray
stevenson's skin whoever you are
dolph lundgren's skin let's do this i'm
just saying i'm all for this
and uh i would i would love for her for
him just putting this
out there to possibly go somewhere i
think give it a shot
let him let him have a shot at it i
think he could develop something really
really uh involved personal harrowing
and just bad ass violent too you know
like
it needs to be i think that's the thing
is you need this to be a cinematic game
absolutely and i think neil druckmann
does the whole thing with naughty dogs
they make their games cinematic
experiences this could be it
this this would be i would love it i'm a
hundred percent for it
guys do you hate the idea of neil
druckmann doing this
leave your thoughts down below really
you're gonna play as the people who
killed frank's family i know i'm really
championing for a guy who's very
divisive on social media like
he is a he's a very divisive personality
i'm all for it leave your thoughts down
below
hit that like button if you if you want
to
see you guys
you